welcome to your tv and movie news
welcome to sidetrek so the cinemas are
really struggling at the moment and the
one thing we've seen over and over again
in the last 18 months is films being
delayed well there's news of one more
film getting at least a 12-month delay
the new sylvester stallone movie the
samaritan was penciled in for this
summer but has now been pushed back to
august 2022
the reason for this primarily a
cluttered schedule for the cinemas in
the next few months
julie savoring director of overlord and
braggy f schutz writer of the escape
room have been working on this gritty
superhero movie for the last few years
and it was all ready to be released but
again thanks to covid we'll be seeing it
in 2022
one film however that's rumored to be
making a big comeback is real steel
watch that watch that
[Applause]
the movie's over a decade old and
didn't really have the massive impact
for hugh jackman in the cinema that they
were hoping for but its release on
netflix last year during the lockdown
saw a huge spike in new viewers
and sean levy has been talking in
interviews saying that he's in
conversation with hugh jackman about
making a sequel this robot boxing movie
was maybe ahead of its time but it's a
class movie and i would really love to
see a sequel
in our last news video we talked about
takawatiti and his announcement that he
is working on a flash gordon remake he's
currently writing the script because the
only thing about mr watiki though is
he's not a lazy bugger he's already
working on several other projects
including the announcement this week
that he is going to be focusing his
attention on his star wars movie
now watiki isn't new to the star wars
genre he has been a cast director on the
mandalorian series
so let's see what he does with his very
own movie
he says he's really looking forward to
bringing his style while respecting the
cinematic feel of the star wars series
tim burton has been working on an eight
episode series for netflix based on the
adams family or primarily based on the
character of wednesday adams this is
being described as a coming-of-age
series
and actually i think it's
a genius idea wednesday adams has gone
to college there's a series of murders
on the campus a monstrous series of
murders and wednesday not only is trying
to deal with how she's becoming a young
adult and trying to fit in in a college
but then also having a detective twist
trying to solve this series of murders
it really really sounds exciting but
let's be honest tim burton has a little
bit of form of taking brilliant ideas
and making them shockingly bad
i will never forgive him for a nightmare
before christmas
that film should have been
amazing the the premise was so clever
and don't get me wrong it's not a bad
film but it's one of those movies that
should have been so much better
let's hope he doesn't do the same again
but the big news this week
is that catherine zeta jones
has been officially signed on to star as
morticia adams now i absolutely love
that news and i think she is ideal for
the role tisha is a huge character in
this series and having somebody right to
play that part is vital if this series
is going to really succeed
but to be honest gomez is always the
primary
[Applause]
they're going to crash
[Applause]
[Music]
you meant to blow them up of course why
else would a grown man play with trains
he's the most important person to get
right so if they've got somebody grating
for him
like they have done in the past then
this series can work
[Music]
however they got louis guzman do it now
i love lily guzman and loads of things
that he's done in the past but i cannot
quite see how he's going to be
gomez
but hey
let's give it a chance this show
if tim burton doesn't ruin it should be
really really exciting and the old guard
is coming back for a sequel now if
you've seen the old guard with schiller
easter on the lovely shoes they're on
literally i can watch do anything i
could i could watch that woman wash up
more than happily for like days um but
if you watch the old guard
the the news that a sequel is in the
pipeline shouldn't really be shocking
but
it really really smashed it out the park
for netflix they got great numbers as
this film was released early in lockdown
last year
it did really really well
so
yeah a sequel is definitely officially
now on the cards writing is already
pretty much done and pre-production will
be starting early in 2022 that's the
news for this week the week that saw the
first what if episode drop and something
that i've left quiet on this video for a
reason so i'm going to be doing this
video every saturday morning 12 o'clock
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification so you never miss it and
tell us what sort of things in the
comments you want to see in the future
thanks very much and uh see you next
time
[Music]